[Musique]
bonjour à tous dans la tradition
antillaise comme africaine pour faire
réfléchir un sujet pour donner un
conseil ou même faire un reproche
on commence par le rêve on raconte des
histoires cela permet d'ouvrir un
imaginaire commun afin de cheminer
ensemble au moment de mourir
un homme demande à dieu quelle est la
différence entre l'enfer et le paradis
dieu lui propose visiter les deux
endroits pour se rendre compte par lui
même
ils partent en enfer ils prennent un
chemin traverse un champ montrent une
colline il arrive sur un village en bord
de falaise
il marche au centre du village
les rues sont propres et soignée et de
très jolies maisons l'homme se demande
s'il est vraiment en enfer il rentre
dans un restaurant
hélas à maître d'hôtel s'approche il
leurs attaches fermement chaque bras
avec des tiges de fer l'homme s'installe
à table et plats arrivent ils ont l'air
délicieux tous plus succulents les uns
que les autres
l'homme regarde autour de lui et tout le
monde essaye de manger mais avec les
bras tendus mais plat tombe au sol tout
le monde s'énerve ça râle harlen se
retourne vers dieu ça y est j'ai ma
réponse c'est les tiges de fer c'est ça
le problème
dieu sourit lui proposa temps de la
seconde visite ils partent pour le
paradis
il traverse un champ plus une forêt il
arrive sur une plaine et là il y à un
village bordé par une rivière et un
grand lac ils marchent jusqu'à l'entrée
du village
et là il rentre dans un restaurant un
maître d'hôtel s'approche et le ratage
fermement les bras avec des tiges de fer
l'homme s'installe à table et plein
arrivent ils ont l'air succulent plus
succulents les uns que les autres à pic
sans il regarde autour de lui il voit
chacun tout le monde 2 par 2 s'installer
l'un en face de l'autre et chacun prend
un plat et donne à manger à la personne
en face de lui la collaboration
nous y voilà nous avons tous connu des
projets cauchemardesque où tout le monde
se bouffent le nez pendant des semaines
comme des projets ou c'est magique on a
l'impression d'être entre amis et en
famille
en 15 ans d'expérience j'ai commis
suffisamment d'erreurs dans le domaine
de la collaboration pour venir partager
mon expérience avec vous on peut dire
que moi aussi j'ai connu l'enfer comme
le paradis je m'appelle christophe qu'à
la berre je suis compteur coach en
intelligence collective et cofondateur
d'une start-up snj games nous utilisons
l'imaginaire à travers des jeux des
événements des récits des histoires pour
transformer les comportements afin de
favoriser la collaboration depuis mon
enfance j'ai toujours été passionné de
sport d'équipé notamment de comportement
héroïque
quand une personne est amené à se
dépasser pour le collectif à l'image de
ce joueur de football il se retrouve à
défendre à un compte quatre il n'a
quasiment aucune chance
il continue sa course il sent une
déchirure dans la cuisse il poursuit
quand même sa chevauchée et au prix d'un
effort dont je vous laisse imaginer la
douleur réussi un tacle éblouissant
qu'est ce qui amène une personne à
donner autant pour le collectif
voilà des inspirations que je recherche
pour transmettre dans l'entreprise afin
de favoriser l'engagement des équipes en
entreprise la collaboration sera une de
vos préoccupations principales trouver
les ressorts qui permettent à chacun de
trouver sa place aux équipes de
travailler ensemble de s'entraider sera
la clé la russie de vos équipes de vos
projets et la vôtre
il ya quelques années il ya quatre ans
exactement
j'ai mené une enquête auprès de mme
écoles
au sujet de la collaboration de la
coopération de l'intelligence collective
en termes de définition et d'expérience
je me suis aperçu que pour la plupart de
mes collègues ils ne percevaient pas la
différence entre coopération et
collaboration et pour être honnête j'ai
découvert moi même à travers ce travail
me suis rendu compte aussi que pour la
plupart d'entre eux ils n'avaient pas
vécu d'expérience collaborative n'avait
pas d' imaginaires ouvert sur la
collaboration n'avais pas eu cet effet
whaou de travailler ensemble
alors pour leur faire comprendre
l'importance de la collaboration
j'ai décidé de leur raconter une
histoire mon histoire
quand j'étais étudiant je faisais partie
d'une troupe de théâtre
chaque année nous partions un week-end
au mois de mai pour aller créer notre
spectacle
le premier jour en 3 heures toute la
troupe écrivait la trame et pendant le
reste du week-end nous retravaillions
ensemble retravaillions ensemble pour
garantir la cohérence scénographique la
troisième année quand je suis rentré
chez moi je me suis aperçu que si le
spectacle comportait une scène
importante pour tout le monde
pour moi je n'avais rien à défendre je
n'avais pas trouvé ma place réellement
dans le spectacle je n'avais pas trouvé
le moment le courage pour défendre mes
envies mes opinions
alors après une semaine de tiraillements
j'ai expliqué ma situation à ma troupe
je leur ai dit la boule au ventre que
c'était pas juste pour moi de continuer
alors je m'étais préparé au reproche de
ne pas mettre suffisamment investi de ne
pas avoir l'air t suffisamment tôt je
mettais aussi préparer au chantage
affectif
christophe quand même après tout ce
temps passé ensemble tu préfères un
effort mais pas du tout à mon grand
étonnement la troupe n'a pas du tout
réagit comme j'aurais imaginé
ils m'ont dit comme un seul homme ce qui
est le plus important c'est qu'on fasse
le projet ensemble ils m'ont demandé ce
que je voulais faire
nous avons toujours travaillé
pour que je puisse intégrer mon bout de
rêve je vous laisse imaginer en
application dans les répétitions la joie
après les trois représentations pour moi
d'avoir réalisé mon rêve est pour eux va
voir de m'avoir permis de le faire si
j'avais décidé de continuer sans avoir
rien à défendre sans envie j'aurais
coopérer comme le violoniste coopèrent
sous le regard du chef d'orchestre
j'aurais fait de mon mieux c'est sûr
mais ce projet n'aurait pas été mieux
quand la troupe a décidé d'intégrer mes
opinions
mes envies ils ont décidé de collaborer
avec moi je faisait maintenant partie
d'une équipe et j'étais prêt à tout
donner pour elle au début d'un projet
c'est important de savoir si nous
voulons collaborer ou coopérer afin
d'éviter les frustrations
alors bien sûr mes collègues se sont
empressés de me dire le théâtre c'est
bien mais ce n'est pas l'entreprise avec
les objectifs la pression la performance
ici c'est pas le monde des bisounours
et c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'en
entreprise
on quitte pas un projet comme moi j'ai
failli quitter ma troupe de théâtre on
se désinvestit progressivement on donne
moins tout simplement absentéisme manque
d'implication travail bâclé en
entreprise comme ailleurs la force
collaborative est essentielle pour
résoudre des problèmes créatif et
complexe mais surtout pour garantir
l'implication de toute l'équipe et c'est
aussi valable dans les couples nous
arrivons en couple avec nos envies nos
projets nos rêves
si nous coopérons nous allons passer un
temps infini à négocier le contrat
implicite le quotidien jusqu'à que l'une
des deux personnes prennent le lead et
que l'autre se retrouve à vivre les
rêves de son conjoint
si nous collaborons nous voulons vivre
nos rêves et nous voulons que
autre puisse vivre ses rêves aussi ce
n'est pas facile tous les jours
c'est une belle promesse et une belle
aventure
et comme dirait fernando pessoa et mais
ces données qu'est-ce qu'on peut donner
de plus que d'aider l'autre à réaliser
ses rêves
maintenant qu'on a visités l'enfer
ensemble
j'ai quand même une question pour vous
est-ce que c'est l'enfer parce que les
gens ne veulent pas collaborer ou ne
savent pas à collaborer pour répondre à
cette question en tant que coach j'ai
développé un modèle d'analysé des
interactions collective le besoin de
réciprocité
quand nous donnons nous attendons
quelque chose en retour si vous me
donnez un cadeau pour noël vous attendez
à ce que je vous donne un cadeau au
retour ou au moins un remerciement
quand nous donnons nous attendons en
retour soin de la personne auxquelles
nous avons donné le premier niveau de
réciprocité soit plus tardivement au
niveau du groupe auquel on appartient
le second niveau de réciprocité soit
encore plus tardivement à l'extérieur du
groupe
nous avons besoin d'un retour chaque
personne un seuil de réciprocité qui
dépend de son histoire de son expérience
avec les autres membres de sa culture
et si nous dépassons le seuil il ya une
frustration qui n'est plus les
frustrations grandissent plus la
collaboration devient difficile voire
impossible pour collaborer il faut
éviter ces frustrations
il faut comprendre et accueillir son
propre cercle de réciprocité et
comprendre le cercle de réciprocité des
personnes avec lesquelles on veut
interagir afin d'ajuster les échanges
était un moyen de favoriser des échanges
que le courant passe comme l'on dit que
ça soit fluide
est ce qu'il ya une formule magique pour
ça la bienveillance la communication
l'écoutent
les espaces de rencontre c'est important
prendre du plaisir ensemble
tout cela est essentiel mais il ya un
ingrédient spécial quelque chose qui
pousse à se lier à s'entraider qui
permet d'être résistant frustration
souvenez vous de mon exemple avec ma
troupe de théâtre
si vous êtes à l'endroit de vos rêves
si vous faites quelque chose qui vous
tient vraiment à coeur vous rayonnera et
vous aurez envie de le partager avec la
terre entière et à cet endroit
les autres ont envie de vous rejoindre
voilà pourquoi c'est important que
chaque projet comporte un bout de rêve
de chacun imaginez tous les rêves réuni
collectivement dans une même barque y
compris ceux du manager ou du chef de
projet voilà une belle aventure
voilà une belle promesse
dans les projets que je coach je mesure
le niveau d'implication et devant
j'essaye de faire exprimer la part de
rêve à tout le monde
voilà les questions que je posais je
vous encourage à vous les posez dans vos
projets qu'est ce que tu as à défendre
dans ce projet dis moi quelque chose que
tu es heureux de faire dont tu es fier
pour ce projet quelle est la
particularité dans cette équipe
la chose que personne ne pourrait faire
comme toi avec ces questions je mets en
avant pour chacun le fait que la
réussite du projet est aussi sa réussite
personnelle
si vous n'avez rien à défendre si vous
ne vous retrouvez pas dans les objectifs
du projet le niveau d'implication baisse
ou baissera à long terme et je vous
laisse imaginer l'impact sur le projet
final ensuite je demande à chaque
personne tout au long du projet ton
activité ton engagement va t-elle dans
le sens de la rue
de l'équipe ou de ta réussite
personnelle les projets l'entreprise les
relations humaines
c'est très complexe il y aura toujours
des conflits
mais si vous assurer que chaque personne
est impliquée parce qu'elle porte un
bout de rêve à une singularité reconnu
par l'équipe ait agi pour le bien de
l'équipe
alors là c'est gagné pour finir
collaboration et coopération
ce ne sont que des mots et vous devez
choisir si vous voulez emmenez avec vous
vos rêves
si vous voulez aider les autres à vivre
les leurs et vous assurer que les rêves
de chacun ou bien trouver une place à
bord ingénieurs architectes artistes
comédiens artisans hommes femmes
nous sommes tous des créateurs quotidien
tous nos projets commencent par une
vibration à peine perceptible par une
envie folle de naître au monde un rêve
qui se propage pour bâtir de nouveaux
mondes pour créer des nouveaux possibles
pour explorer de nouveaux chemins pour
concrétiser tous ses rêves
prenons soin de nos rêves ensemble
explorons les chemins de la
collaboration
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]